merrick garland is the top law
enforcement officer in america and one
of the richest members in joe biden's
cabinet worth an estimated 20 million
dollars
garland served as a federal judge for
more than 20 years earning a salary of
141 000
to 230 000
every year when he was nominated by bill
clinton to serve as a federal judge in
1995 he had to submit documents which
detailed his finances the filings show
that garland made good money in private
practice
200 000 in 1993 when he worked for nine
months at arnold and porter but he also
had a robust fortune outside of his day
job with 3.5 million dollars in assets
and zero debt on the 1995 filing garland
split his holdings into various
categories cash listed securities real
estate and so on but the largest
category was called trusts worth about
nine hundred and ten thousand dollars
an attachment showed that those trusts
were all from his wife's family so as of
1995 much of garland's net worth came
from his in-laws
lynn garland's grandfather was a
well-known new york lawyer who served on
the state supreme court he also advised
former u.s presidents harry truman and
franklin delano roosevelt her father
went to harvard for both undergrad and
law school and made his living as an
attorney garland and his wife were
eventually handed a property in
manhattan followed by another property
in greenwich connecticut one of the
richest towns in an already rich state
for wealthy families looking to pass
down fortunes transferring property has
a ton of benefits
these families hand off the real estate
itself
then they pump cash through that real
estate by paying rent to their errors
and that's what apparently happened here
with garland recording six hundred
thousand dollars to 4.6 million dollars
of rent as income over a period of 12
years
over the years his fortune swelled
according to financial disclosure
reports filed between 2004 and 2021 at
the start of the period garland declared
2.9 million dollars to 6.5 million
dollars of assets
10 years later that range had grown to
7.6 million dollars to 28 million
dollars today it's 8.6 million dollars
to 33 million dollars
however the bulk of his fortune is
concentrated in more liquid investments
like stock funds and cash accounts
[Music]
you